Chuck is that time again
oh you say oh it's explainer time oh
it's later time I thought it was
performance review or something oh you
know the principal's office so what we
got here is every now and then the
planets mercury in particular seems to
get all the headlines goes into
retrograde oh my goodness I used to go
out with a girl who used to say that her
communications are all messed up because
mercury is in retrograde and so the
emphasis there is used to go out it's
true it's true so I just thought I spent
a few minutes explaining for what ritual
grade is is that so wrong so here's
here's what's going on through most of
human history human civilization
prescience as manifested by methods and
tools and experiment and hypothesis okay
that goes back only about 400 years so
before them the world was what it looked
like to people and it or what it felt
like to people and the urge to test an
idea wasn't really a thing yet this is
how you can get Aristotle to say that
heavy things fall faster than light
things in proportion with how heavy they
are so if you have two rocks one is ten
times as heavy as the other do it fall
10 times as fast he just said that and
everyone believed it and it never
occurred to anyone to test that to test
it they take a heavy rock and a light
rock and drop them they will fall it
exactly the same rate and hit the ground
at exactly the same time so this
experiment did not require a grant from
the National Science Foundation to
conduct so I cannot overstate the
importance of of the value of a
hypothesis and an experiment to verify
it and what role that played in in
catapulting civilization forward so
Aristotle must have been a very
charismatic person because he's just you
know just like you know if you have a
rock and you have a smaller rock that's
about ten times he said you know that
the bigger 100 10 times faster believe
me right so yeah it's just well he was
influential everyone knew he was smart
he's unimpeachably smart right so so
there you have so now here's the thing
if everything is what it looks like then
if you look up at the night sky earth is
in the center of the universe okay it's
clear that that's the case this Sun
rises over there and sits over there and
the moon rises and all the stars rise
and set the Bible you know it is it's
earth is like not subservient to the Sun
in the birthers like there and later on
you create the Sun in the moon okay so
if you look at the time sequence as
described there so in Genesis in the
opening phrases so that had great
influence on public's belief and
understanding of the world so we're in
the middle of things okay so then the
Greeks notice well anyone who looked up
would have noticed that not all the
stars are just stationary there that is
some stars move against the other stars
okay everything rises and sets but
there's some objects that move
what are those objects that group the
Greeks call them Wanderers okay because
they just moved and by the way if you
call something a wanderer implicit in
that label is the statement that you
don't know what the hell they're doing
right yeah they're just wanders they're
just wandering okay so let's let's count
the wonders there is mercury we have
Venus Mars Jupiter Saturn
the Sun and the moon these are the seven
Wanderers and wanderer in Greek
translated is planet s that's where we
get the word planets there you go okay
and so back in ancient times there were
seven planets the Sun and the moon
included that all went around the earth
and do you trace the names of the seven
days of the week to these seven planets
mixture of Norse legend Germanic and
Roman gods but they all correspond ok
point is if you're at the center and
everything is moving around you
it's odd if anything ever decides to
slow down stop and then go backwards
forgot something it's like what what are
you doing you're Jim you what are you
doing ok all planets all planets have
this motion at some point in their
orbits relative to ours ok
it just mercury does it more often than
the other so there's more occasion to
speak of this happening with mercury
than with others the point is if you
think they're moving against the
background stars and you're in the
middle of it all right you're gonna come
up with a word for this and your word is
retrograde you think the thing is moving
backwards right do you think it is so
why not have a word for it you think the
Sun is actually coming up above your
horizon so you have a word for that it's
called sunrise you think the Sun is
disappearing behind the horizon in the
West you're gonna call that sunset
there's an entire vocabulary we have
that is pre Copernican Copernicus put
the Sun back in the middle of the known
universe it's there's a hope that we
retained to this day retrograde is one
of those words so it's not that
complicated
now that we know in the era of science
and experimental testing that the Sun is
in the middle of the known universe all
planets
now the Sun is no longer a planet it's
that it's the star that we go around so
that got taken off the list the moon is
not a planet because it goes around us
that got taken off the list
so we went from seven planets to six
okay so how did we do that we lost the
Sun in the moon but the planet count
gained what us right gained earth began
earth right yep because earth is now
just one of these others that goes
around the Sun so the planet count has
not been constant you know the history
of civilization yeah well from seven
down to six we lost two gained one so
here's earth just one of one of the
planets are the launderer so what does
this look like if you are in this sort
of race track around the Sun the laws of
gravitation show that planets that are
closer will orbit faster they not only
move faster they complete a year in
their lives faster than planets that are
farther away from the Sun than us okay
so here we are and here we see mercury
catching up to us on this side of the
Sun moving against the background stars
it overtakes us and now it's going
around the back stretch so when it
overtakes us it goes back that it's good
it looks like it's going the opposite
direction as it passes us and goes
around the Sun it looks like it slows
down stops and goes back you don't see
this in three dimensions on the night
sky you just see a line trace its way
back but this is just the natural thing
that any one of these planets will do
and in fact one of the retrogrades for
the outer planets is earth going around
the Sun okay we go around the Sun and
our angle of view on it changes in such
a way that it looks like they went
backwards so the retrograde motion for
the outer planets is because of Earth's
motion and the retrograde motion for
Venus and Mercury are because of their
motion and it's all because of what it
looks like to us and it's no different
from you being like you've ever been on
a bus or in a train and is another train
right next to you and then and then you
start moving but it's really smooth and
it looks like the other train is going
backwards yes right you see you've seen
this all right
it's not actually going backwards you
are overtaking it okay that's how that
works that's cool that's a great way to
put it because anybody who's been on the
train has had that that chance and it
looks like the Train is absolutely going
in the opposite direction like and who's
moving which way and if you're sitting
in a backward seat
you get all confused okay so astrology
predates the methods and tools of
science so all of the astrological
vocabulary and representations and
language and and assertions traced to a
time when earth was the center of the
known universe and you would see planets
entering areas of the Scott entering
houses areas of the sky where there's a
constellation because people believe
that these stars were like put there for
our benefit and they're they're just
points of light on an inside surface of
a of a dome an inner surface of a dome
and that therefore they're real things
but in modern science we shove these
stars are scattered in space they're
completely scattered they're not actual
things so the hundred ways till Tuesday
for why the foundations of astrology
have no justification in a
scientifically literate modern world but
people still cling to it I think it's
it's gives the gives them some something
to do every morning it's calm read my
horoscope yeah that's a way to offload
accountability for things that are or
will random things that are happening in
your life it's a way to not take
responsive so that way I see it it's
it's great to have a reason the worst
thing in the world for something
happened with no reason it's like there
you can't like there's something about
being a human being where when to think
that something is completely just random
without meaning for some we can't accept
that we can't accept it we're like kiddo
no no no if
was good then it was God was bad it was
the devil that you got reason for it all
because the Greeks had this because they
had a God controlling everything right
there the list of gods were all they
were in everybody's situation my
persimmon rotted right so so there's a
God for that I've got an app for that
we've got a God for that so I what's
interesting is we study this in
psychology where not only are we
uncomfortable with random things
happening without some reason that we
can know and reach and touch the the the
thing that happens and the reason that
makes it have to be on the same
magnitude right so it's not just some
crazy person who kills John Kennedy it's
it's the president that was shot oh it's
happenin CIA and you need the Russians
and any Cuba and you need this do you
need an explanation commensurate with
the thing that it is that you're trying
to explain but of course Shakespeare had
it best that said it best when he says
The Fault dear Brutus lies not in the
stars but in ourselves
damn you William Shakespeare in York
taking take what's the prob will you
take responsibility for your own actions
Wow yes so basically oh oh by the way oh
by the way by the way mercury was not in
retrograde
during the corona verse but had it been
then you'd have people say oh there it
is there must have been and that's why
you have explanations so in anybody's
life which is sufficiently complex
socially culturally financially there's
always something good and always
something bad unfolding that you can
either ignore or embrace it or and match
up with some other force that you want
to then blame or credit for that
happening and so what you need to do is
look at the statistics if you really
wanted to analyze
you look at the statistics of good and
bad things that happen to you
all right and how often does that take
place and then when it lands on an
astrological event but what are the
chances of that well it's a hundred
percent chance that one of these is
going to land on something is happening
in the night sky and but think of the
hubris of that that somehow the universe
cares about you just think about that
yeah with all that's going on out there
have you seen earth in a photo from
space is this dot the pale blue dot that
Carl Sagan saying speaks so poetically
uh yeah and if you you're gonna say all
of these planets and all these things
that dwarf do you not be earth is
relative to Jupiter Jupiter has
blemishes the size of Earth okay but
you're gonna say that Jupiter in this
constellation at this time of day
affected you and you were born on this
speck of dirt we call Earth that takes
hubris and was hubris just thinking of
yourself as being important relative to
other things and usually without
justification absolutely Wow so well
with that I'm having that for dinner so
I'm now I know you're batshit crazy so
yes so there it is so there's always
something bad and always something good
happening and you always got something
to blame it on if not yourself that's
the real takeaway here blame yourself
and by the way little children whose
lives are not complicated yet they're
not really into astrology they're inter
exploring the world it's like when you
get into middle school Oh does he like
me does she like me or they were gonna
be boyfriend-girlfriend are we gonna go
out together is it but it don't have
enough money is they like to learn how
to drive well I get in an accident all
that gets complicated and then that this
is when you have the rise of astrology
in people's lives right and you also
have the rise of that little paper thing
that you put together and pick a number
and if you like me for everyone over 80
they remember no what are you talking
about my son
okay I'll open it up and you say the
answer on it for you yeah I don't even
know what they're called but she came
home well not the other day so when
school was still in she came home in one
and she was like damn pick a number I'm
gonna tell your fortune but they'd have
to pick a color and then you put a
number which is probably just as
effective so yeah just let me end this
by saying I think when people reach for
things outside of themselves to bring
meaning or understanding or solace and
that's a real human need as a real human
motion emotion and I'm duty-bound as a
scientist to be to share with people who
are curious what the objective truths
are that the methods and tools of
science have learned because that's the
actual world we live in and so but I'd
want to do it without giving people hope
right you know the phrase luck comes to
those who are prepared yeah and you have
others there's one some coach a baseball
coach there's some batter always blessed
himself okay before he went to hat and
the in the coach that works if you're a
good hitter it's like funny it's you
know it's just just you want to credit
or blame things okay but I think at the
end of the day you were seeding you were
ceding control of your own life you're
seeding your accountability your
responsibilities and yes it's harder to
shoulder those but I think in the end
it's more rewarding because then you
become master of your own destiny
or a better master of your own destiny
than you ever would have been for not
having done so Wow all right we gotta
call it quits there all right Chuck as
always thanks for doing this with me
or all right Neil deGrasse Tyson here
your personal astrophysicist okay
[Music]